le thermomètre affiche un degré c'est
une journée d'hiver plutôt confortable
pour les Trifluviens mais frigorifiantes
pour 11 marins en provenance des
Caraïbes et d'Amérique du Sud pas du
tout rompu aux rigueur de l'hiver ils
vivent depuis trois mois à bord de ces
trois bateaux remorquables bloqués au
port de Trois-Rivières des bateaux qui
ne sont toujours pas autorisés à prendre
le large car il ne répondent pas aux
exigences de Transport Canada les marins
ont commission de ramener en Amérique du
Sud ces trois bateaux remorqueurs qui
ont été achetés ici au Canada sous
l'entreprise guyanaise Becca marine qui
s'en est porté acquéreur un navigait
avant opérer par exemple sur le fleuve
Saint-Laurent et là comme ils ont été
vendus à nouveau propriétaire et qui
doivent emprunter les eaux océaniques
pour se rendre à leur destination mais
on peut facilement imaginer que des
travaux à faire pour adapter les
remorqueurs à cette nouvelle réalité là
pour s'assurer que le trajet se fasse en
toute sécurité et donc là de Transport
Canada qui s'assure du suivi des travaux
et va donner l'autorisation une fois que
tout sera fait en conformité pour que
les remorqueurs puissent quitter peur de
Trois-Rivières avec des places à quai
pour leur permettre d'effectuer des
travaux les conditions de vie à bord
sont rudimentaires ces bateaux ne sont
pas conçus pour héberger des marins pour
de long séjour encore moins en période
de grand froid alors arrivé en octobre
ils étaient 25 14 sont rentrés à la
maison 11 patientes encore pour se
changer les idées certains d'entre eux
fréquentent le foyer des marins à
Trois-Rivières c'est d'ailleurs grâce à
cette organisme qu'ils ont pu obtenir
des vêtements chauds et adaptés à
l'hiver autrement même s'ils y sont
autorisés ils ne s'aventurent pas en
ville ils préfèrent rester au chaud ici
Julie Grenon Radio-Canada Trois-Rivières